what up gamers in today's intro i
decided not to yell
just kidding i installed the chaos mod
on all your pcs
ah it's chaotic it is already i'm dead
this is the most insane mod to ever be
made in any video game what is going on
on my screen i don't even know
we have this blue bar at the top of our
screen and every time it goes to the
right
something incredibly weird will happen
to each of us
i just got oil trails now oil follows me
around
oh my gosh everybody's running up to me
right now everybody's chasing me
don't worry carl the bar is almost on
the right side don't worry ah
flashbang now gentlemen you're probably
wondering
what is the challenge of the video what
is the challenge whoever has made the
least amount of money in gta in 30
minutes
has to stand on the side of a road
wearing a hot dog costume with a sign
saying i
suck hot dogs what no
why is my screen flickering oh my eyes
hurt i can't see anything
oh my god everybody's getting out of
their cars just to chase me around
i i blow up if i don't go 52 miles an
hour my car's busted
no i'm gonna blow up i blew up
i'm standing on top of them i'm standing
on top of them
i can't move anymore holy crap
carl what's going on
oh i'm getting abducted by aliens
oh no
no i just killed all of them chris how
much money do you have
230 dollars i currently have 313 i'm
beating chris how much do you have carl
chandler
230 225 so what is your guys's plans to
make money so you don't have to be a hot
dog
story mode cool my guy is now a roblox
character
oh i have a plan the vehicles are going
half the speed it's so slow
come on i don't want to wear a hot dog
costume stop making me go backwards
i will not be an embarrassed
embarrassing glizzy i wait wait i just
got
an automatizer shoot something with it
see what happens i would but there's a
never-ending staircase
oh my gosh oh my gosh explosive zombies
i can't go near people there's a force
field around
me wait it says give everyone an
atomizer
everybody in the entire game has one now
oh my god
look they do don't know where to go oh
oh my gosh
oh my god what why
why are people chasing me what the heck
chris look everyone's just chasing me i
think everybody oh
ah gravity doesn't exist anymore
scooter brothers who are the scooter
brothers
oh that's cool i think it's impossible
to do anything when i'm
flying i have a plan
i want money all pedestrians are cops
oh my god has anyone made even a dollar
yet
yes i don't think so i've actually
lost more due to zombies coming and
blowing me up for no reason
so chris if you were to make money where
would you go
uh if i was to make money it would be
the casino
no carl that was a lie so that way he
wouldn't make money
did they just spawn a bus on me jimmy
can i do anything to make money
you have to make the money legit in game
chris stop trying to cheat
i will always try to bend i'm invisible
i'm in the invisible boatmobile they
spawned a ferris wheel on me
so what are your guys's thoughts on the
chaos mod so far i want to die
this makes gta so much fun it honestly
does
like even if we weren't doing this
challenge i would play with this much
because like you never know what's going
to happen oh
no find a left and right movement was
disabled give me money
give me money i can't turn the car give
everyone
a mini gun i just got turbo cop there's
a lady jaywalking there with the minigun
i got her i'll get her don't worry
bus i couldn't see it ah why did i get
teleported to mount chiliad again
i can't do the story mode if i keep
getting freaking teleported
oh my god i was about to say i literally
have lag as a side effect
wait wait wait what would you you just
got money
i just got a quarter of a million
dollars randomly
no i swear i didn't do that i swear i
didn't ring
it wait no they just launched me up for
no reason
vehicles explode on impact great oh cool
now there's a hay baler on me
the purpose is to make money how are you
guys doing so far
so far i'm falling down a mountain for
the second time
i'm literally just beating up people an
alien ah an alien just shot me
everybody caught on fire wait wait i
have midas touch will this turn gold
oh yo i can make anything turn to gold
gold gold yo oh oh my gosh
yo yo yo i figured it out i figured it
out minus touch if you touch a person
they turn into a money bag why was jimmy
getting this
lucky all right boom money money you get
midas touch and i get teleported to
heaven
guys i got a bmx bike yeah
i don't even care about the win anymore
i'm going for the bmx hops baby carl how
much money have you made so far what's
your plan i
have 328. my game crashed
i can't even stay alive for more than 30
seconds to get money
20 minutes remains whoever has the least
amount of money in 20 minutes
has to be a hot dog on the side of the
road all right as long as i don't have
the lease
i will admit i freaking hate whatever's
going on here can you switch it back to
normal please mod
you know gta 5 the game known for
loading really fast
yo my game speed is at 0.2 now i can't
sprint your job
i i have a quarter of a million dollars
chris how much do you have i can't tell
you right now there's some random guy's
face on my screen
oh 250 taylor how much do you have 224.
what do you have carl 328 chandler if
you don't find a way to make some money
you're gonna have to wear a hot dog
costume on the side of a road apparently
on the side of a mountain
chandler just go to a casino just bet it
on like something with the best odds and
if you wouldn't then you'll be ahead of
both of them
i've gotten the worst luck i can't even
make it to a casino
all right here we go rainbow traffic
let's go
whoa all right i was teleported to a
mountain yeah it happens
why would you get me out of the car hmm
why am i
on the ground hey everybody stop raging
for five minutes i just want to let you
know
ten minutes remain ten minutes until we
decide
come here please oh my gosh every
vehicle just exploded
why does that give me three stars i just
got three stars because all vehicles
exploded and now the pedestrians think
they're cops
will you give me money heli chopper oh
my god this car sucks but lamar won't
get out of it
ah airstrikes
oh teleport to heaven i'm literally
falling in a truck
oh my god oh my god of course there's a
tree here why wouldn't there be a tree
that i just get
slammed into
why would you kill yourself he killed
himself french fries
how are you attempting to make money
carl i'm attempting to make money by
murdering everybody and just grabbing
their cash
how about a punch in the head give me
that money all right so we got to do
this
mission but i keep blowing okay wait i
blow up every time i spawn now
wait did you have spawn uh extreme grief
jesus i think so
you lose money every time you respawn oh
wait are you negative
chris is losing a ton of money because
he keeps dying over and over again
spawn deadly why carl how much money do
you have
three hundred and thirty four dollars
chandler how much money do you have i've
194.
chris how much money do you have 250 and
i have 240 000 so
still chandler if you don't find a way
to make some money you're gonna have to
wear a glizzy costume on the side of the
road
i'm literally moving in slow motion all
right now i'm killing people
i'm killing people for money skip skip
skip skip skip i since i have
such a ginormous lead i don't even need
to play i'll just leave my my game like
this
wait wait do i get money from this i'm
sorry i have to shoot you i need to make
money
it's nothing personal wait wait wait
wait wait why can't i
no loki i just like helping trailer
because he has snacks
oh please this is the only chance i have
for a mission
you might make money if you win this i
don't know i just this is my only hope
chandler for your sake try to make some
money yo this mod is actually pretty
dope but i don't want to be a glitzy
because of it
why did i just die what lamar just blew
up for no reason
he likes spicy cheetos and spicy doritos
why do you like spicy food so much
probably not the best time to ask that
sorry there's only one minute left yeah
you should probably focus on making
money
man oh they're on the scaffolding and i
spawned a helicopter
yeah let's go how much money do you have
chandler 194 carl how much money do you
have
428 okay good good good come on give me
a million dollars really quick please
how much money do i have oh snap i lost
40 grand balls gone
chris how much money do you have i still
have 250 dollars
taylor's on 194. so he might catch up to
you come on baby
gentlemen 30 seconds remain i figured
out how to turn the plane
and then i died chandler you have 30
seconds to make some money or you got to
wear a hot dog costume
pray your next blue bar chandler is one
that gives you money
come on please it's almost there give me
money
what'd you get chandler super run and
super jump
three two one gentlemen pause your game
read how much money you have i have 180
000 chris
250 dollars taro 408 251
i think we're gonna need to fact check
that one once again 194
chandler you made the least amount of
money which means you have to wear the
hot dog costume
and hold the sun
yay
i hate this
all right we are done